la tension ne cesse de monter depuis
près d'un mois entre étudiants et
gouvernement le 14 janvier dernier
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants ont
manifesté leur colère dans la capitale
hellénique
la cause un projet de loi controversé
l'abhorré la veille par le ministère de
la protection des citoyens et celui de
l'éducation
ce projet suggère notamment la création
d'un corps spécial de policiers non
armés introduit dans les universités
afin d'en assurer la sécurité
les universités sont des structures
publiques crucial qui font l'objet de
menaces de sécurité
outre les menaces de désastres naturels
ou d' attaques cybernétiques les
universités grecques font l'objet
d'actions violentes de certains groupes
très politisé les universités grecques
sont souvent le théâtre de violences
entre groupes d'orientations différentes
en octobre dernier un groupe d'étudiants
cagoulés avaient pris à partie le
recteur de l'université d'économie
d'athènes en l'insultant et en
l'agressant directement dans son bureau
du point de vue des étudiants on voit en
cette mesure une nouvelle répression de
la politique très sécuritaire du premier
ministre
kyriakos mitsotakis ils font venir la
police dans nos universités
ils veulent nous réduire au silence
pendant qu'ils détruisent notre avenir
[Applaudissements]
afin de moderniser l'environnement
éducatif
il devrait utiliser les millions d'euros
destinés à cette police pour ouvrir nos
écoles avec de réelles mesures de
sécurité l'introduction d'une police
dans les universités grecques
supprimerait le principe d'auto gestion
pourtant respecté dans la majorité des
universités européennes dans la plupart
des pays de l'union européenne la police
n'est en effet autorisé à entrer dans
les campus qu'après une autorisation du
rectorat
une nouvelle mesure restrictive qui
s'ajoute à la longue liste de décisions
2007 a kiss accusé de répression sur
fond de mesures pour endiguer la
pandémie